ali adhère au système monétaire invité
du journal le monsieur europe de l'udf
jean françois denis sidérurgie plus de
10000 licenciement au groupe usinor son
pdg claude etchegaray s'explique iran 35
morts à ispahan
les premières images de nos envoyés
spéciaux juliette gréco 30 ans de
chansons un nouveau visage
madame monsieur bonsoir sos ces lettres
gigantesques domine désormais la ville
de longwy au sommet d'un crash
impressionnant à 110 mètres du sol et
qui donne la mesure de l'inquiétude qui
a gagné une bonne partie de la lorraine
et du valenciennois jour après jour nous
arrive en effet la confirmation de ce
que l'on attendait depuis l'annnonce de
la restructuration de la sidérurgie
française et dans leur sécheresse ces
chiffres là font mal plus de vingt mille
suppressions d'emplois en tout huit
mille 500 ch et sacilor ce lac 15 cents
à paris outre aux 300 à creusot loire et
plus de 12000 à usinor usinor où
plusieurs centaines de travailleurs ont
manifesté cet après midi devant le siège
parisien du groupe
oh
communiqué rusi nord uniquement 5000
suppressions d'emplois sont les 6470
lusine de donna 5500 à longwy 550 à
valenciennes 400 à blagny club 411-1 des
cris de colère des gorges qui se sert et
les prises de position sont simandou
pensons qu'ils peuvent être évitées
notre pays peut produire de l'acier en
quantité on en a besoin dans notre pays
on a besoin aussi à l'extérieur
là ce sont des considérations de profit
qui font en sorte que ses décisions sont
prises c'est simplement pour le but du
profit et rien d'autre il y a des
solutions notamment à travers la
cinquième équipe la cinquième équipe qui
ne serait ce que pour lucy gordon a
notamment la chine la plus menacée
créerez mille emplois dans cette
entreprise
alors ce sont les études photo voir
maintenant il faut voir l'amélioration
des sur notre travail
le travailleur qui en meilleure santé
sarr est moins souvent
et enfin il ya un tas de choses qu'il
faut calculer nous on a déjà calculé
c'est l'effet que ça pourrait avoir si
vous voulez et bien c'est fait qu'une
herman par l'os parlant c'est très très
bonne chose
je
ce qui n'est pas dit en même temps c'est
le délai dans lequel et qui sera
nécessaire pour amener les emplois de
substitution dans ces bassins et quels
efforts les pouvoirs publics
parallèlement à cela vont pouvoir
apporter et faire rapidement et dans les
délais qui s'imposent pour maintenir sur
place les populations
alors il faut dire que pendant ce temps
pour de s'égarer le pdg d'usinor annoncé
devant le comité d'entreprise son plan
de compression du personnel
il en était ensuite expliqué pour
jacques merlino et si vous voulez je
crois que le personnel comprend
certainement difficilement quelle peut
être la réaction d'un président français
décision est ce réellement pour usinage
quillon la dernière grande vague de
licenciements je le considère jules
considère et si vous voulez je crois que
ces opérations sont nécessaires pour la
survie du rouquel n'ampute en rien notre
position commerciale puisque nous aurons
encore dans tous les domaines une
surcapacité par rapport à la demande du
marché qu'il est vain de croire que nous
sommes en état de crise en fait nous
sommes dans une situation de marché qui
durera et par suite si ces solutions
n'avait pas été prise et si je ne
prenais pas ses décisions aujourd'hui
c'est 35 mille emplois qui risquerait
d'être supprimées à terme c'est vous
s'il y aura d'autres implantations
entreprises en lorraine et dans le nord
eh bien nous nous employons pour se
faire non seulement les pouvoirs publics
la datar le fonds qui a été créée et
tous ceux ci sont des éléments qui est
permettront j'en suis convaincu de
trouver des réimplantations d'autre part
au niveau la direction du groupe il y
aura un homme dont ce sera la mission
unique de s'occuper du reclassement de
aux ouvriers et d'essayer de trouver des
implantations nouvelles le chômage il
sera encore question avant la fin de
l'année et à l'assemblée nationale
puisqu'il se confirme que le parlement
pourrait si j'ai deux ou trois jours en
session extraordinaire après le 20
décembre pour examiner précisément
différents textes sur le fromage
décision définitive à l'issue du conseil
des ministres de demain
ils sont finalement sept à avoir adopté
le sms
après une semaine d'incertitudes les
italiens ont fini par dire oui vous
savez qu'avec les irlandais les anglais
il s'était montré très réticent à
bruxelles la semaine dernière
leur décision a tout de suite été
qualifiée de courageuse par la
commission européenne et de très positif
par l'elysée visiblement le poids de ses
partenaires a beaucoup joué dans la
décision prise tout à l'heure par giulio
andreotti le progrès le président du
conseil giulio andreotti qui a annoncé
ce matin à la chambre des députés que
l'italie a des rhétiques médiatement et
sans réserve au système monétaire
européen
c'est une décision courageuse de la part
de julian des antilles car si
politiquement
l'italie ne pouvait pas ne pas adhérer
au système monétaire européen
économiquement la situation est
dramatique
comment un pays qui connaît un taux
d'inflation de 12 à 15% par an peut-il
accepter les règles plutôt rigide d'un
système monétaire européen qui ne permet
pas à la lyre de varier de plus de 6%
c'est toute la situation économique du
talent il est en cause
même si le président giscard d'estaing
hier soir et le chancelier helmut
schmidt ce matin ont promis par
téléphone et du lait
une aide économique substantielle de la
part de la communauté
il ya donc un problème économique car
les italiens seront certainement appelés
à d'autres sacrifices mais il ya aussi
un problème politique qui sait si le
système monétaire européen ne sera pas
fatal au gouvernement de rio où plus tôt
qui sait si le système monétaire
européen ne sera pas un bon prétexte
pour faire tomber le gouvernement de
rôti il y ait un débat actuellement à la
chambre des députés et il pourrait même
y avoir un vote demain les socialistes
ont déjà décidé de s'abstenir
mais les communistes eux sont tout à
fait opposés à cette adhésion immédiate
de l'italie au sm si les communistes de
votre contre c'est la crise politique
tout dépend des communistes en tout cas
une décision qui réjouira la plupart des
européens de coeur et j'imagine tout
d'abord jean françois deniau qui va avec
nous avec la double casquette de
ministre du commerce extérieur et de
rapporteur pour l'udf du dossier europe
alors tout d'abord au ministre du
commerce extérieur cette décision des
italiens est ce qu'elle va désormais
permettre à l'écu d'être viable mais je
crois que c'est une très bonne chose
parce que ça montre que ce système
monétaire européen
le premier commentaire avait dit c'est
pas un très grand succès c'est pas
attractif et bien fait commentaires
étaient manifestement trop pessimiste et
le fait qu'il l'italie ait décidé de se
joindre immédiatement et sans réserve
montre que c'est quelque chose de
sérieux
et donc nous devons être très content il
ya aussi je crois un intérêt pour la
france
au fait que l'italie a rejoint le
système monétaire européen à la fois le
système est plus large
et puis bah nous nous revenons au centre
si vous voulez nous nous trouvons de
nouveau au milieu de l'europe ce qui est
notre vocation est ce qui est très
important
alors parlons un petit peu de dossiers
europe dont vous êtes le rapporteur pour
l'udf eu un dossier qui tient en sans
proposition la plus spectaculaire étant
la création d'un plan marshall européen
qui doté d'un fonds de 500 milliards de
francs qui permettrait de relancer
l'économie européenne et donc l'économie
française on va vous dire un le plan
marshall a tout de suite après la guerre
c'était un plan pour une économie ce
sinistre est ce que l'europe est
sinistrée c'est un peu c'est à dire que
le plan marshall comme je le conçois pas
le plan marshall européen
il faut l'utiliser
et en europe et en france pour relancer
l'économie notamment les investissements
la recherche enfin certains noms de
domaine où il faut que nous évitions
absolument de prendre du retard par
rapport aux autres pays
mais il faut aussi d'utiliser à
développer les capacités d'achat dans un
autre série de pays qui sont nos clients
normaux et c'est ça que les américains
avaient fait après la guerre ça m'a
frappé tout à fait de voir que nous
avons actuellement en europe une
capacité de production peut être de
l'ordre de 30% qui n'est pas employé et
c'est exactement la situation dans
laquelle les américains se trouvait
après le dernier conflit mondial
ils ont en quelque sorte créé du pouvoir
d'achat chez les autres en relançant
l'économie des autres ce qui est
beaucoup plus efficace et beaucoup plus
sûr que de relancer directement sur le
plan intérieur
je crois donc l'europe doit prendre
conscience des problèmes économiques qui
sont les siens à l'heure actuelle et
restaurer une base économique solide et
prospère en europe notamment par une
mesure comme celle que je propose
et puis après passer à un autre stade
qui est de dépasser le niveau en quelque
sorte commercial et s'occupait de ce qui
est le plus fondamental qui est de
recréer une civilisation européenne avec
tout ce que cela comporte la mention la
démocratie alors vous proposer d'autres
mesures tout aussi spectaculaire nous
n'entrons pas dans le détail je retiens
simplement c'est cet abaissement
progressif de la durée hebdomadaire du
travail à 33 heures
est-ce qu'il vous semble que toutes ces
mesures peuvent aider à la cohésion de
la majorité une cohésion qui semble un
peu ébranlé à propos de l'europe précisé
que cela ce sont des mesures concrètes
et y en a de très nombreuses qui ont
pour but que l'europe apporte quelque
chose de positif de saintes de n'être
dans la vie quotidienne de nos de nos
compatriotes très souvent reproché de
beaucoup trop lointain mystérieux en
amont sais pas à quoi ça sert eh bien il
faut que sur le plan économique d'abord
mais aussi sur le progrès social sur la
façon de vivre des français d autres
pays européens l'europe apporte quelque
chose je crois que c'est déjà un terrain
sur lequel tous les gens raisonnables
devraient se mettre d'accord
et puis aussi saoulé une ligne politique
générale qui est dans ce rapport qui est
que je ne suis pas du tout partisan
d'une europe qui remplacerait nos états
qui se substituerait anoeta je crois
d'ailleurs que plus personne ne souhaite
il télé
mission ce qu'il faut clairement c'est
une europe dont on a besoin parce que
c'est l'espace le nombre que nous
n'avons pas nous mêmes nous français
face notamment aux superpuissances c'est
une offre qui apporte quelque chose à
chacun de nos pays et c'est donc le sens
général du du rapport que j'ai remis à
l'udf et je crois que l' os x il s'agit
de défendre les intérêts français et sur
le plan européen
un très grand nombre de français
devraient considérer que c'est à la fois
positif et raisonnable et si je peux
résumer vous cherchez à payer envie de
lui dire faire en disant tout cela ce
n'est pas à l'égard du rpr lui même pas
ce que sa position très franchement je
ne la comprends pas du moins telle
qu'elle a été exprimée dans un certain
nombre de cas la querelle sur la
supranationalité me paraît complètement
dépassée depuis des années dans de très
nombreux cas d'ailleurs ce qu'on peut
reprocher à l'europe c'est pas d'en
faire trop c'est l'enfer pas assez et
moi j'ai essayé de façon complète et
dans le respect très précis de
l'indépendance nationale et de nos
intérêts français de faire progresser
cette affaire européenne parce qu'on en
a besoin parce que c'est une dimension
qui nous manque
alors moi je n'ai pas compris jusqu'à
présent ce qui valait comme
justification n'est ce pas des attaques
qui ont été prononcées qui m'ont paru
extrêmement excessive
ce que je voudrais c'est que ces
élections elles ne soient pas
complètement détournées de leur objet il
s'agit d'envoyer à strasbourg sur le
plan européen les meilleurs français
pour défendre les conceptions française
les intérêts française et c'est ça qu'il
paraît raisonnable deuxième et dernière
journée du voyage en corse du premier
ministre ce matin ajaccio vannes enfui
venaco au coeur du parc naturel régional
de lille et puis une série de petites
étapes en plaine et aux quatre corse
accueille bon enfant de la cad la part
des corses même si aujourd'hui le mot
d'ordre de grève générale lancé par les
syndicats était plus suivie à bastia
qu'à ajaccio leit motiv de raymond barre
tout au long de ses quarante huit heures
je suis là pour que toutes les promesses
soient tenues par les syndicats les
partis de gauche et les autonomistes la
manifestation prévue à bastia à
l'occasion de la venue du premier
ministre n'a pas été tellement plus
importante que celle d'hier ajaccio en
revanche le mot d'ordre de grève
générale lui a été mieux suivi coupures
de courant magasins fermés etc
ceux qui comme d'habitude n'a pas semblé
émouvoir
raymond barre il faut dire que le
premier ministre avait noté dans la
journée une volonté de décrispation de
la part de certains élus de l'opposition
je trouve tout à fait normal de recevoir
du mieux que l'on peut le prémice de la
france nous sommes en france ici et que
je sois de la position de la majorité je
suis de l'opposition c'est une raison de
plus pour pouvoir le lui dire et lui
expliquer ce que j'ai à lui dire et les
raisons de me demander mon opposition
les objections que j'ai à formuler à la
politique gouvernementale
je ne suis pas du tout pour la politique
de la chaise vide vous faire un bilan
des mesures annoncées par mais se bat
pour un bilan des mesures annoncées par
monsieur bart mesures importantes
concernant les communications routières
mesures intéressantes concernant enfin
intentions intéressantes concernant les
mesures le transport aérien mesures
intéressantes concernant la rénovation
rural et anne intérêt certain portée aux
choses de l'intérieur je suis donc
relativement satisfait le premier
ministre pour sa part s'est félicité des
entretiens qu'il a eus avec les corses
pendant deux jours sur le terrain loin
des péripéties de la politique
parisienne référence bien sûr au vote
d'hier à l'assemblée nationale une fois
de plus monsieur bart répété que cette
politique là ne l'intéressait pas et je
voudrais redire ici ceux que je n'ai
jamais cessé de répéter ce n'est pas moi
comme premier ministre qui prendrait la
moindre initiative pouvant porter
atteinte à la cohésion de cette majorité
j'ajoute que ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé
et je dirai ce qui m'a satisfait au
cours de mon voyage en corse c'est que
je me suis entretenu non seulement avec
les élus de la corse qui appartiennent à
la majorité mais aussi avec des élus de
la corse qui appartiennent à
l'opposition mais qui pratique une
opposition constructive et kiko dans un
esprit démocratique accepte et pratiquer
le dialogue
que souhaiter de mieux pour un pays
comme la france et que souhaiter de
mieux dans une région comme la corse où
il ya tant à faire et où ce qu'il y à
faire des passes deux bouts
où les clivages politiques qui sont tout
à fait normaux mais qui doivent
s'effacer
lorsqu il y à des tâches d'intérêt
général à remplir
après une deuxième journée passée
notamment à visiter l'intérieur de l'île
et à s'enquérir des difficultés
particulières rencontrées par les
habitants
monsieur bart a quitté la corse non sans
avoir rappelé que le développement
économique de la corse n'est pas une
question de court terme
nous continuerons à travailler avec les
responsables de la région a dit le
premier ministre
pour atteindre les objectifs prévus
objectif prioritaire alléger les
inconvénients de l'insularité et juguler
le chômage très important ici surtout
parmi les jeunes et bien après cette
parenthèse dans l'île de beauté le
premier ministre pourra se replonger
dans les problèmes politiques au sein de
la majorité depuis la petite phrase de
jacques chirac la semaine dernière ce
que certains appellent maintenant
l'appel de cochin et qui a provoqué
quelques remous au sein du rpr je vous
parlais hier du mouvement de recul de
lillers guichard il y a trois jours de
l'agacement plus manifeste de lucien
neuwirth et bien aujourd'hui cela
continue et daniel brême oui
effectivement c'est l'ennemi sorte
qu'ils invitaient le groupe du rpr pour
n'être plus qu'à parenté elle proteste
ainsi contre la manière dont jacques
chirac a publié sa lettre chauffage
appel de cochin
avant même que le conseil politique du
mouvement qu étaient réunis en et été
saisis ya pas qu elles n'ont ils pas
quelle il ya eu d'autres réactions c'est
ainsi que jean bonhomme devant ses
collègues qui est très silencieux a dit
qu'il ne voulait plus être manipulés
comme un pion ou un petit soldat
et puis ces gens crecer qui a décidé lui
de bouder toutes les réunions du groupe
parce que m'at-il dit je suis pris en
sandwich entre mes électeurs qui me
demandent pourquoi je met la pagaille au
parlement et les milito qui me demandent
pourquoi je suis aussi tiède avec
jacques chirac et on parle pas du cas
d'alexandre sanguinetti nom fut
effectivement mais devant ces
turbulences cours de la baie qui a vu
hier jacques chirac a promis qu'on
s'expliquerait sur ce problème mardi
prochain et que d'autre part jacques
chirac viendrait devant le groupe aux
environs du 15 janvier jacques chirac
qui va changer l'hôpital exactement pour
sa rééducation
bon alors maintenant est-ce que à votre
sentiment c'est la forme de l'appel de
jacques chirac aux français ou bien le
fond qui a le plus gêné
le soir de sa diffusion c'était
lancement mais là maintenant c'est plus
complexe
à part les députés inconditionnels
chiraquiens et bien c'est le langage qui
choque c'est à dire les propos excessifs
les insinuations et les arrière pensées
mais sur le fond il y à une modification
car les députés disent en fait l'europe
c'est une aventure
nous ne savons pas comment elle sera
d'autre part la france et honnêtes dans
ses intentions mais les autres pays ont
des arrières pensées alors peut-être que
pour l'avenir il vaut mieux être prudent
et sur cette analyse se greffent tout à
fait autre chose
la perspective d'une campagne faisons
recettes axée sur une allemagne trop
forte et également l'ouverture d'un
créneau à tous les mécontents ce qui
selon les stratèges du rpr permettrait
d' atteint 24% et à votre sentiment leur
père va-t-il pro tour et une prise une
vrai cri et bien non alors là claude
labbé vraiment a tenu à mettre ce soir
les points sur les i le débat sur
l'europe c'est une chose le soutien
gouvernement s'endette union par deux
motions de censure pas de rupture de la
trêve
autrement dit ni dissolution ni bien sûr
élections politiques encore avec cette
déclaration de michel rocard devant la
presse anglo-américaine la troisième
force existe c'est l'alliance rpr pc
l'émergence de cette coalition politique
européenne est un fait de première
grandeur
cette alliance est bien bizarre
hétéroclite et soudés par la plus
dangereuse des patios le nationalisme
michel rocard dont edf ce risque de
coupures de courant demain entre 9
heures et 11 heures le mot d'ordre de la
cgt touchera en effet les centrales
thermiques et nucléaires vidéogrammes de
france n'est plus cette société dont la
sfp et la librairie hachette se
partageaient le capital avait perdu de
sa raison d'être depuis quelques années
son pdg roland dhordain a décidé de
mettre fin à ses activités
un énorme dossier demain sur la table
ovale du conseil des ministres celui de
la sécurité sociale un déficit imposant
qu'il faut combler
simone veil doit trouver 15 à 18
milliards de ressources supplémentaires
laurence graff un nous explique le
pourquoi de si les français devaient
financer mêmes leurs soins médicaux ou
prévoir leur pension de retraite ce
serait presque un retour au moyen-âge
c'est pourquoi lille un déficit de la
sécurité sociale à part est inquiétante
en réalité si le déficit actuel est
important 5 milliards de francs
ils ne représentent qu'une petite
fraction de l'énorme budget de la
sécurité sociale - 2 2 %
le problème c'est qu'il risque de
s'élargir
on prévoit qu'il pourrait doubler
l'année prochaine pourquoi cette
situation prenons les trois grands
budget de la sécurité sociale les
allocations familiales elles ont un
excédent un milliard et demi le déficit
vient de l'assurance maladie
2 milliards et de l'assurance vieillesse
quatre milliards et demi ses déficits
on peut les expliquer par exemple en
france comme dans les autres pays
d'ailleurs les dépenses de santé
s'accroissent plus vite que les autres
la technique médicale s'améliorent mais
elles coûtent cher et puis de plus en
plus de français sont couverts par la
sécurité sociale
quant aux pensions de retraite depuis le
temps que la sécurité sociale existent
elles sont versées à plein régime
les recettes de la sécurité sociale
elles augmentent moins vite
d'abord parce que nous sommes en période
de faible croissance économique
et puis aussi parce que la population
française vieillit il y a et il y aura à
l'avenir plus d'inactifs et moins
d'actifs donc moins de cotisants les
solutions du gouvernement donc demain à
l'issue du conseil des ministres
le crédit à la consommation va baisser
vous l'avez su dès hier soir si vous
étiez avec nous à l écoute de cartes sur
table c'est un effet rené monory qui l'a
annoncé le crédit va diminuer de 1,5
pour cent dans les prochains jours pour
plusieurs secteurs notamment
l'automobile
rené monory qui a également confirmé
pour les deux ans à venir une stagnation
du pouvoir d'achat à l'étranger
maintenant de bons progrès dans les
négociations salt a déclaré jimmy carter
il y à quelques heures il a même annoncé
une prochaine rencontre entre son socata
d'état thousands et andrée gros micro
sur ce problème de la limitation des
armements stratégiques interrogé
maintenant sur la situation en iran et
bien présent carter a déclaré qu'il
espérait sans réserve que le chat
resterait au pouvoir et que celui ci
avait l'appui et la confiance totale des
etats-unis en iran justement après deux
jours de manifestations religieuses et
politiques
c'est le vide dans les rues de téhéran
le vide et le calme après la team de le
tumulte
ainsi d'ailleurs que dans toutes les
autres villes iraniennes iranienne
pardon à l'exception d'ispahan les
heurts entre populations soldats qui ont
débuté hier soir ce sont en effet
poursuivis ce matin l'armée aurait tiré
dans la ville
et l'on parle de 35 morts et de près de
600 blessés
bernard benyamin et daniel mailhot nous
adressent maintenant leur première
portage de téhéran en effet l'aéroport
de la capitale n'a été ouvert
qu'aujourd'hui seulement voici donc le
tout premier reportage d'antenne 2 sur
ces manifestations combien étaient ils
au sus un million deux millions de
manifestants
plus peut-être toujours est il que les
défilés de dimanche et lundi font partie
de ces événements qui marquent à jamais
l'histoire d'un pays pour la première
fois toutes les autorités religieuses
téhéran et les principaux leaders
politiques menaient une action commune
leur but dénoncer la politique du chat
nous manifestons parce que c'est la
journée des droits de l'homme parce que
le gouvernement un militaire la sais
c'est que de renforcer la répression et
qu' il a systématiquement massacrés ces
opposants qui ont descendu ces trois
derniers mois dans la rue sans arbres ou
sans aucun moyen de défense
en fait cette manifestation et pour
demander l'arrêt immédiat de ces sacs et
pour le rétablissement de la
constitution de 1906 pendant deux jours
teheran vidé de ses militaires aura donc
appartenu à ses habitants pendant deux
jours la capitale iranienne aura surtout
été une formidable caisse de résonance
pour tous et religieux qui criait haut
et fort
allahu akbar dieu est grand dieu c'est
le maître mot de la situation en iran
c'est la formule magique pour tous ce
petit peuple des faubourgs de téhéran
qui se raccroche à l'image de son
représentant sur terre l'ayatollah
khomeini il est le seul à avoir tenu
tête aux chats il est présent
dans tous les esprits à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui en iran la contestation
et même la révolution passe
nécessairement par la religion la
religion
personnellement je la vois comme la
spiritualité qui est qui accompagnent
les luttes politiques actuellement en
iran et dans ce sens je ne suis pas
séparer de cette spiritualité de cette
si vous voulez de l'âme de cette lutte
la révolution en iran passe par cette
force qui est politique et spirituelle
et qui a fait descendre le peuple
iranien dans les rues mais ça ne vous
aime pas tout de même de manifester à
côté de deux jeunes femmes qui portent
le voile traditionnelle ou tchadors pas
du tout elles ont la liberté de
s'habiller comme on veut mais vous
revendiquez la vôtre également certains
oui c'est à dire que si demain un
gouvernement islamique s'installer en
iran est-ce que vous accepteriez de
porter le voile
non je ne porterai pas et vous pensez
que ce sera possible qu'on vous
permettra de ne pas le porter la
question
de toute façon en ce moment ne se pose
pas pour moi mais je ne porterai pas ça
c'est sûr de toute évidence le problème
se posera à terme et pour le moment on
préfère l'éviter
on préfère se faire asperger d'eau de
rose qui purifie cela sent bon et cela
fait naître parmi les manifestants un
sentiment d'union qui n'existera peut
être plus demain
quoi qu'il en soit les manifestations de
dimanche et lundi ont démontré avec sans
doute une force jamais égalée que le
peuple iranien ne voulait plus du régime
du shah il est nécessaire qu'ils tirent
de conséquences nécessaires à ce que le
peuple à manifester
c'est à dire selon vous quelle pourrait
être l'attitude et des autorités
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas prévoir
exactement ça dépend
de leur intelligence et de leur sagesse
de comprendre la volonté unanime de leur
peuple
est-ce que vous accepteriez par exemple
de faire partie d'un gouvernement
d'union nationale dans le cas actuel et
avec la situation la situation actuelle
non je ne participerai à aucun
gouvernement
et je ne prendrai pas la responsabilité
du gouvernement parce que je constate
qu'il est absolument inutile pour le
moment en tout cas rien ne change
à la fin de la manifestation lundi
l'armée avait déjà repris position dans
les rues de terre l'employée blessée
lors de l'attentât du bazar de l'hôtel
de ville à paris il ya dix jours est
morte hier soir georgette de féret âgé
de 67 ans avait dû être amputé des deux
jambes à la suite de l'explosion demande
de contrôle judiciaire à l'encontre de
robert hersant cette décision était
prise par les représentants des
syndicats de journalistes qui pensent
avoir une réponse du juge avant la fin
de la semaine
deux doigts de sport ce qui d'abord avec
le slalom géant de piano carvalho chez
les dames aux trois premières places
hanni wenzel du liechtenstein devant la
suissesse marie thérèse nadig et
l'allemande irene et pl en quatrième
place position donc perrine pellen
il prend ainsi la première place au
classement de la coupe du monde 79
et puis voile toujours pas de nouvelles
du trimaran d'alain colas encore une
fausse angoisse aujourd'hui on avait
bien découvert une épave au large de la
désirade une des îles des antilles mais
ce n'était pas le même raisin et puis la
page de la météo aujourd'hui une forte
tempête en bretagne ailleurs alternance
d'éclaircies et d'averses mettant
toujours doux pour demain encore se
tendent ouf avec beaucoup de nuages et
des pluies passagères sur la plus grande
partie du padd du pays de belles
éclaircies sur la région méditerranée
dernier rendez-vous avec l'actualité sur
antenne 2 après 23h30 c'est à dire au
moment
après les dossiers de l'écran avec
pierre alain et puis avant de nous
séparer une page spectacle une grande
dame de la chanson elles sont rares en
france vous savez fait sa rentrée au
théâtre de l'athénée tout la présente
sous forme de devinette
elle faisait scandale après la guerre
elle a chanté les plus grands poètes
contemporains de queneau prévert
je pense que vous avez déjà mis un nom
sur ce portrait et georges bégoux va
nous montrer son nouveau visage
je vous laisse en sa compagnie bonne
soirée à tous et à demain
gvt est beau en pis aller
se moquer et de l'airé du vent tout va
trop vie a aimé le flou et le flanc
la fureur de sang
les bains
la vie 120
juliette gréco une nouvelle chanson de
pierre seghers et un nouveau visage
aussi non pas un nouveau visage le mien
le mien que
que j'ai décidé d'assumer mais vous ne
devez pas simplement à la fantaisie de
votre coiffeur se sentait si de mon
coiffeur ne me touche guère quand je
veux quelque chose c'est moi qui le veut
et puis c'est une manière d'agressivité
comme ça c'était une manière de dire
peut-être aussi peut-être un appel un
appel au secours aussi peut-être ça
dépend parce que je suis tellement
inquiète que je me dis voilà c'est moi
si vous m'aimez vous même récit vous ne
m'aimez pas je serai très malheureuse
mais c'est comme ça dans ce nouveau
récital il ya peu de nouvelles chansons
on va retrouver plusieurs oeuvres qui
ont émaillé votre carrière oui oui au sa
part sa part de cette usine imaginer de
la rue des blancs manteaux en continuant
par par un plein de choses à 7,7
ce pas une rétrospective bien sûr parce
que ce n'est pas possible on peut pas
chanter 300 chansons où ses ressorts je
ne sais plus combien sur cette chanson
là on essaie de faire une sorte d'
équilibre comme ça de résultat de trente
ans de chansons beau souffler de petit
poisson par exemple thomas péter poisson
gigean petit oiseau qui veulent un petit
poisson un petit oiseau s'aimaient
d'amour tendre
mais comment s'y prendre quand on est
dans
un petit poisson un petit oiseau
s'aimaient d'amour tendre
mais comment s'y prendre quand on est là
où est-ce que vous avez acquis vous
sentez une sagesse particulière avec les
années ou bien y at il encore de cette
folie des années 40 50
je ne peux pas être ça je suis folle ces
folles je suis pas une folle furieuse
mais je suis fan c'est certain j'ai le
pas du tout des réactions normales ni
dans mon métier n'est ni dans
l'existence je suis quelqu'un qui peut
être totalement heureux et complètement
désespérée mais je suis folle comment
vivez vous lorsque vous déserté la scène
pendant quelques mois
oh là là je ne suis pas folle du tout là
là je suis je fais enfin retour sur moi
même je sais j'essaie de me
désintoxiquer justement de tout de
toutes les choses qui me font mal alors
je respire je suis dans ma campagne je
gratte mater et puis quand j'ai un peu
de terre pas beaucoup mais un petit peu
et puis j'ouvre ma fenêtre sur autre
chose que la maison d'en face et c'est
un grand luxe c'est très important de
pouvoir penser puis j'essaie d'écrire
en
bien sûr nos unes des ora
20 ans d'amour c'est la mort folle
will fois tu pries ton bagarre
et chaque main le se souvient dans cette
chambre sans vers sous les éclats des
vieilles tempère lui rien ne ressemblait
à rien j'avais perdu les moissons
conquet
dumont
non
mon doux tendre mon merveilleux
de l'eau claire jusqu'à fin du jour je
t'aime encore
non